hello everyone how are you guys doing
[__]
me hello everyone how are you guys all
doing I hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today we are here with
Merchant God my [__] all right hello
everyone how are you guys doing hope you
guys are having a wonderful day and
today we are here with episode number 11
of worthless 2 Wall Street so today we
are just going to be Merchant I guess so
if you guys uh remember where we picked
off last episode I really didn't recap
how much we were at it was probably
around 71 to 72 milish I started off
with 5 mil a little over a month ago so
this merching series definitely has
progressed pretty [__] fast so
nonetheless we will get right into the
merges we currently have going on so as
you can see here in the grand exchange
all of our rubies have sold for 1319
which means I made 11 GP on all those
wanted to make more cuz I bought them
overnight however was not able to then
as you can see I sold on a ton of CHA or
Elder chaos tops I made like 80k off of
5 of them and one of them I bought to
see what the price was but then I was
also able to buy another four down here
for 1 mil practically and I'm going to
be able to sell them on for 1130 which
means I will be able to make um God I'm
bad with mad about 500k in total off of
these so little update all of the Elder
chaos rope tops have sold two more
bought so I'm going to list those back
up for I believe 113 o wait what 1 1.2
mil Maybe could sell them on for that
whatever we'll raise the we'll raise the
price I'll try that out we'll see if we
can sell them on for that um torch
ornament kit has bought so I'm going to
try to sell that on hopefully it doesn't
drop on me I always just seem to pick
these up at the wrong time but uh yeah
I'm going to throw these up for what
should I do 12 150k we'll try
that and as you can see one of those Rob
tops already sold so it was a good idea
to up the offer on that I'm probably
going to buy some more but up the
overall offer just a little bit all
right so back again and both of the
light blisters have sold however no more
bought which I believe means someone
undercut me so I'm going to go throw in
an offer for some more light ballistas
real quick offer has been placed as you
can see torture ornament kit has bought
or sold I guess for
12.1 mil so I'm going to see what I
could be able to buy and merch another
one for real quick um looks like I can
buy it for around I'm going to try to
buy it for
11575 and see if I can buy one for that
I think that's the exact surpris I
bought one for earlier then three Elder
Ro Toops have bought
for uh 1 mil 17K so I'm going to go sell
them on for 1 mil and
197k and I should be able to sell those
on these uh these smaller robes or not
smaller robes but the RO bottoms are not
buying so I'm just going to take those
out and probably up my offer on the tops
by a little bit no way so I'm over there
at Corp I'm going to throw this in the
merch video but I was at Corp just got
an Arcane sigil at 22 KC we were in a
fourman so I definitely got split that
but that's insane all right there we go
so two light ballistas have bought so
far so we're going to list those up for
88k we'll make uh what no 270k off each
of those so that' be a 500K profit um
one more Elder Road top bot I'm just
going to keep that offer in because it
probably going to just keep buying stuff
I'll list that up for a pretty high
price since it seems to be going up up
these uh ring of the gods don't seem to
be selling which is a little
disappointing so I'm going to lower that
to 107 or 10
972k because that is what the guide
price is going to just throw them in for
that right now and I don't remember what
I bought them at so I don't know if I
make money off of that or not I think
it's pretty close though logging in now
and we are going to see what has bought
and what has sold so we've been able to
sell off the Elder top it seems that
they've gone up so I'm going to take out
that offer for those the Ring of the
gods have sold for pretty much 11 mil I
don't know what I bought them before I
cannot remember but we've had six
ballistas buy now I'm going to lower the
sell price on these to probably I don't
know how it says it's 3.4 mil to sell
cuz none of those sold whatever I'm
going to lower it to
3366 K and they'll sell eventually for
that one way or the other so as you can
see we're going to make 250k pretty much
on all these which would be 1.5 mil in
total bought a torture ornament kit and
a torure ornament kit currently is
12.45 MIL God bro this thing is just all
over the place I don't know it had a uh
it had a quick jump up I guess to 12 mil
so it's gonna have a quick fall down but
I'm just going to list it up for 12 well
we'll go
11 860k and we'll try to sell it on for
that so we'll let all that buy and sell
I probably should invest some of this
money into something shouldn't I instead
of just letting it sit around right I'll
find something let's do it definitely
terrifying but we're going to try to
merch one of these eternal glory so
we'll see how that goes hopefully it
doesn't drop on me too hard okay boys so
came back from uh getting something eat
playing soccer [__] getting my
brother the whole the whole shitload of
[__] I had to do but uh none of these
light ballistas have sold no more bought
which is a good thing but the torture
ornament kit has sold for a 300K profit
and an amulet of eternal glory has
bought which is probably the biggest
merch or definitely the biggest merch
I'm doing this entire Series in one item
so I'm going to go ahead and list this
up for probably around 34 I'm going to
try like
3445 okay and if it doesn't sell for
that before I go to bed then I'm
definitely going to drop the price
because I don't want to get stuck with
this overnight there we go so we were
able to okay well that's not what I
wanted to look at but we were able to
sell off the Amulet of eternal glory
actually a really good merch there about
700k and I'm going to keep doing these
if I am able to so 33 702k we're going
to try to buy one for that we go we are
logging in in the morning and a torture
ornament K has bought I can not get
another Amulet of eternal glory I
lowered my offer by a lot um a ton of
these light blesss have sold no more of
these Elder chaos
tops so pretty much alls we have is a
torture ornament kit which isn't bad I
guess unless it dropped on me which [__]
bro it does every night and you think I
just you know understand that and just
not [__] with it
but says 10.7 is what I bought for and O
apparently L apparently the price of it
isn't below uh 10.7 there we go so I'm
going to throw it in for 11 35 okay and
uh see if it can sell on for that hey so
we were able to buy a ring of the Gods I
pretty much bought it for what the sell
price currently is which makes sense in
a lot of cases as you can see but I'm
not sure if that was a sell or buy price
and it just took a second but it was the
highest Buy offer in and the reason I
bought it is because I don't believe
ring of the god should be dropping to
anywhere near below 10 mil and I think
they'll go up so even if I'm not even if
I don't manage to sell it for around
this price I have faith that it will go
back up so we'll uh we'll invest in that
a little bit hey there we go so torture
ornament kit has sold so we made a good
600k or so off of that and all of the
light ballistas have gotten done selling
so probably going to invest in another
torture kit I kind of want to find out
what the Buy price of these light
ballistas are CU they're always a good
flip but uh yeah guess not I'm going to
try to buy some Loop and tooth Hales
because you can make 2K per key that you
make so that offer is going to be in
there for a little while and I'm going
to have to find another item to throw
all this money into hey back again so
we're going to sell on this torure
ornament kit for
11.35 I maybe could go a little higher
with it I'm not entirely sure I might go
1139 2K we'll try that and uh go ahead
and make ourselves another 600k on that
another torture ornament kit has bought
another one another one so basically
what I'm going to do is list these two
up while I go to work the Ranger gloves
I'll probably still keep in this is
actually a little bit different of a uh
of some merch is I don't normally do the
ult necklaces first time ever and
ranging gloves as well first time ever
so we're going to list up these torture
ornament kits for
11 11
325k and see if we can get it for that I
could list him up below that but another
150 K couldn't hurt I guess oh my God so
there is going to be some [__] going
down right now so basically two things
have sold which is really good we'll go
over that real quick so torure ornament
kits I bought for 21.5 mil collectively
and they sold on for 22.6 so 1.1 mil
profit on that good good I like it ring
of the Gods I bought for 10151 it
dropped a ton to 9.5 but I was still
able to sell it for 10.4 so I made 150k
to 200k on that nothing Che too good but
I'll take it considering the
circumstances then for uh for the Ranger
gloves I'm going to get back to you in a
second once I realized how much I [__]
up on these ones so Ranger gloves still
an inactive price and it says 19 mil now
if that's true I'll be more than happy
with it let's see this so that says 18
so I'm going to go 18 92 NOP that is not
it so
892k we'll try to sell him on for that
that's 00 not a 900k profit I'm a liar
that would be a 600k profit 500k profit
something like that I'll take that more
than enough all of these tooth and loop
hals have bought and I will definitely
take this because I'm going to just put
these all together as Crystal keys and
uh go from there and then this oul
necklace kit um this is this is a little
risky I've never done this one so it's
going to be something a little different
basically right now um OS buddy is
saying the Buy price is 7.4 mil and and
currently I bought it for 6.6 which
means if that buy price is correct I can
make a lot of money on this so let's go
73 85k and we will try to sell it on for
that all right so I'm going to leave
these offers in for a little bit while I
go make all of these Loop and tooth has
and basically I'll go and see how much
each one of these cost me to get so if
you add this up basically each key that
I am currently making cost me about 40K
I believe in total to be able to make so
hopefully we can make a little bit of
profit on this well actually a little
less than 40 but it is what it is 38 9.8
I do believe really really quickly we
were able to sell on those Ranger gloves
for a cool 600k profit that's so nice I
don't know if I sold them maybe a little
too low but I'm definitely happy with
that 600k profit so let's go as I ended
that last clip bro the ult ornament kit
sold what the hell I made so much money
on that too I bought I made like 700k
off of that I literally just made like
1.4 mil in both of those items combined
that is crazy bro bro all right what is
going on
so why am why am I looking at my face
what do I want to talk to you guys about
well basically over the last week I
really haven't done a worthless to Wall
Street episode I've recorded clips for
all of them have not edited one until
now because I thought I could just pile
them all up and then eventually just try
to cut them all down into a video but to
try to put this in perspective to you
guys basically this video was made up of
about 20 to 25 clips and I have 80 saved
up right now a few are from different
videos and a few are from the video that
I was going to do next there's no way I
can shorten it all down so basically
this is going to be the end of this
video I'm sorry about it I know you guys
are probably pissed but uh just wanted
to shout out my clan chat really quick
if you guys ever want to join it is
right here small exp lamp we're going to
go with that instead of the Wolf Gang
221 if you guys show up in here whenever
I'm on I will be in here and hopefully
we can keep it a little active but yeah
that'll be it for this video basically
what I'm trying to say is I have
practically two to three videos ready to
go so I have like up until episode 14
already made progress on this account is
insane and I can't wait to show it to
you guys so if you guys enjoyed the
video feel free to hit a like if hit hit
the like not a like and if you guys
enjoyed a enough if you can subscribe to
me also comment down below anything you
want to change if you guys are watching
this and it's it's been a little while
I'm just going to warn you episode 12 my
mic will be louder so turn down your
YouTube Sound other than that I hope you
guys have a wonderful day and peace all
right totally forgot cannot forget so um
I have a roommate at college and he
makes videos as well he's been always
having me in his description down below
and I have not been reciprocating the
same sort of love so I'm going to go
ahead and put a link to his YouTube up
on the page now he does FIFA Cod stuff
like that so it's a little different if
you guys want to go sub to him much
appreciated and uh sure he would enjoy
that nonetheless let's get to the outro
[Music]
[Applause]
boys